le commandant taliban modèles rack fat
et ses hommes redoutait ce genre de
points de contrôle avant de renverser le
gouvernement
ils menaient des opérations d'assassinât
contre ses dirigeants ce que le
commandant appelle les corrompus il
avait beaucoup de succès dit il
je mener des opérations clandestines
nous allions de place en place à la
chasse des personnes corrompues les
pires des personnes pour les assassiner
nous quittions les lieux à toute vitesse
en portant des vêtements de civils nous
avions des caches pour nos armes dans
nos voitures
parfois nous assassine ion avec un
pistolet parfois avec
aujourd'hui c'est au vu et au su de tous
qu'ils sont à la recherche de
trafiquants de drogue ces gens
d'opérations qu'elle se consacre
maintenant les talibans pour redonner
aux afghans un sentiment de sécurité
affirme le commandant
la part des chanoines à papa dans le
passé personne ne pouvait aller au
marché le soir à cause des valeurs
surtout à kaboul annaba
la sécurité était très mauvaise mais
depuis que nous gouvernons en moins de
deux mois grâce à dieu le nombre de
voleurs à diminuer
c'est bien ce qui empêche myriam de
fermer l'oeil depuis deux mois pour sa
protection nous avons changé son nom la
jeune femme était juge la cour suprême
un rôle qui lui valait déjà des menaces
sous l'ancien régime celle d'un homme en
particulier un dirigeant taliban qu'elle
a condamné pour violences conjugales
j'étais suivi quand je sortait parfois
il prenait ma photo en faisant des
courses au marché et me l'envoyer à la
maison avec un message
il disait nous sommes tous prêts plus
près encore que la veine de ton cou si
tu te retournes tu nous vers argenteuil
posture la mémoire y aura laisse tomber
cette affaire une femme n'est rien pour
nous juste un instrument ça ne vaut pas
le coup d'envoi y est notre leader
emprise pour une femme
maroni
quand les talibans se sont emparés de
kaboul et libéré les prisonniers son
univers tout entier s'est écoulé les
menaces ont repris par texto et appels
téléphoniques depuis elle mène une
existence de recluse tous les deux jours
elle doit trouver un nouveau refuge pour
se soustraire à ceux qui la menacent
déjà il a échappé une fois à la mort de
justesse
trois jours après la chute de kaboul je
me suis mise en sécurité chez mon oncle
il était 8 heures le soir je mangeais
mon souper quand ils ont lancé leur
opération
il y avait environ 50 talibans avec des
armes lourdes et légères j'ai les images
de la scène sur mon téléphone les
maisons entières a été abîmée six
membres d'une famille de voisins qui
habitait au rez de chaussée sont morts
au cameroun en
masse à la base air prod ni l'ufar un
nom d'emprunt ici aussi vit terrée dans
la crainte d'être découvertes comme
procureur pour la direction nationale de
la sécurité c'est elle qui devait
présenter au juge des éléments de preuve
convaincant contre des membres des
talibans de dèche et d'autres groupes
terroristes aux east and i'm so he and
wallace maintenant ce sont eux qui sont
juges qui sont procureur avocat me
punissent les criminels à leur guise et
le fond sans se soucier du droit de la
justice
ce sont des criminels qui nous punissent
nos rêves sont anéantis
les talibans comme juge jurés et
bourreau c'est ce qui est arrivé à leur
fils raconte cette famille qui
souhaitent témoigner anonymement
appelons le homard il avait 22 ans et il
a été capturé en pleine rue par des
talibans qui l'ont accusé d'un vol qui
se déroulait tout près son cousin qui
étaient avec lui prévenu son oncle qui
aussitôt à chercher dans quel
commissariat de police on l'avait emmené
cet ancien interprète de l'armée
américaine a frappé à plusieurs portes
avant de retrouver son corps inanimé à
même le pavé
droit
ils l'ont tiré une trentaine de fois au
visage à la poitrine dans le bras contre
le mur et son corps était dans la rue il
gisait par terre ils l'ont tué les
[ __ ] quand nous l'avons ramené à la
maison j'ai pris sa tête dans mes bras
et j'avais des morceaux de son cerveau
dans les mains
diack affirment que les talibans par la
suite fabriqué toute une histoire pour
le faire passer pour un criminel mais
qu'au fond s'ils ont criblé le corps de
son neveu de balle c'est simplement
parce qu'il y de la vallée du panjshir
une région qui résiste au pouvoir des
talibans
ils ont raconté toutes sortes de
conneries sur lui pour se couvrir c'est
inutile de se plaindre en fait à qui
peut-on se plaindre ils vont tous nous
capturés
zia crois que s'ils n'arrivent pas à
fuir l'afghanistan sa famille lui sont
condamnés à subir le même sort
les talibans continuent d'affirmer que
ceux qui ont collaboré avec le précédent
gouvernement et les forces étrangères
n'ont rien à craindre qu'ils bénéficient
d'une amnistie ce qui inclut les femmes
juges et avocates des paroles qui ne
rassure en rien la procureure niloufar
et la juge mariam tout faire
en
comment peut-on contempler l'avenir nous
luttons pour survivre sans aucun appui
dont comptes bancaires sont gelés nous
avons peur d'être tué par les talibans
et parfois on se dit que s'ils ne nous
tue pas c'est autre chose qu'il fera
la situation économique nous tuera c'est
sûr grâce à ce chèque est avec quasiment
validé
elles ont crû bâtir un pays plus juste
pour elles et leurs concitoyennes mais
aujourd'hui si maria mini loup phares
sont toujours en vie elles se sentent
complètement dérober de tout espoir le
corps subsistent mais l'âme ni plus
et
par ailleurs les informations
personnelles de près de 200 afghans qui
cherchent à fuir le régime taliban ont
récemment été divulguée par erreur leur
adresse courriel et dans certains cas
leurs photos se sont retrouvés dans des
courriels envoyés par le ministère de
l'immigration des réfugiés et la
citoyenneté certains d'entre eux
craignent que d'autres informations
comme des documents d'identité ou des
numéros de téléphone ne soit désormais
entre les mains des talibans c'est le
cas d'un travailleur humanitaire qui dit
avoir reçu des menaces téléphoniques
phones iphone